just want to bring you the latest
pictures we have now a princess
Charlotte's christening the royal family
leaving the church there on the
Sandringham Estate hundreds of
well-wishers have turned out today to
see the Duke and Duchess of Cambridge
Prince George of course and Princess
child Charlotte they're being pushed in
a vintage pram that we understand des
was the Queen's that she used to push to
have her own children these images are
going to become iconic aren't they very
cute Prince George their Rhiannon mills
a royal correspondent has been in
amongst the crowd talking to people
waiting for the royal family to emerge
and it's quite the reception they were
given Rhiannon yeah and I think that was
a big part of this occasion the Duke and
Duchess of Cambridge they really wanted
to say thank you to all of the people
who maybe sent them cards or their good
wishes when Princess Charlotte was born
back on the 2nd of May but I think those
pictures that we're seeing today they
are certainly unique people will be
wondering exactly how the Duke and
Duchess managed to have such
well-behaved children we saw them
arriving earlier they decided to walk to
church Princess Charlotte's we didn't
get to see much of a glimpse of her to
start off with she was being pushed in
that traditional pram bundled up in the
traditional royal christening gown but
we did get to see a lot of Prince George
once again a very good little boy under
2 years of age you have to remember he
plans to this month and he was walking
alongside his father every now and again
Prince William looking down at his son
maybe giving him sort of few words of
encouragement but he kept on walking
until they got to the church now as well
as all of the general public being able
to be there in front of the church
watching them they were also then
greeted by their very close family and
friends the Queen the Duke of Edinburgh
Prince Charles and his wife Camilla and
also Kate parents the Middletons and
also her siblings
Pippa and James Middleton were there for
that service quite a small congregation
and also included in that congregation
worthy godparents a few surprises ion
who exactly William and Kate decided to
choose rather than opting for their own
siblings or maybe cousins that we'd
expected maybe princess eugenie or
princess beatrice instead they went for
williams first cousin and also one of
princess sorry the duchess of cambridge
also adam middleton her first cousin and
also a few friends as well as godparents
we now know that the family are heading
back to Standring house where they'll
have a nice cup of tea and also a piece
of christening cake which is taken from
the Duke and Duchess's wedding cake so
they'll be enjoying that on what has
been a big day for Princess Charlotte